- Hi everyone, welcome to
our Homeroom live stream.
This is something we
started several months ago.
It's really a way to stay connected
and have interesting conversations
about interesting things
with interesting people.
I'm super excited about our
guest today, Casey Wasserman
but before we get into the conversation
I'll make my standard
reminders reminding everyone
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so
please think about donating
at khan academy.org/donate.
I also wanna give special
thanks to several corporations
and foundations that have stepped up
since we went to the COVID crisis.
We were already running at
a deficit before the crisis
and as you know our traffic
and the types of supports
and programs we've tried
to do have only accelerated
so special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, Novartis and other
folks like the Amgen Foundation
who are long-time
supporters of Khan Academy
and that have continued to
support it going into the crisis
but we're still running it at a deficit
so any help you can provide
is greatly appreciated.
With that said I'm excited
to introduce our guest today,
Casey Wasserman and Casey
good to have you here.
- It's good to be with you Sal.
- So Casey you and I go back
a little while ago you know,
many years, I mean in the
early days of Khan Academy
I remember I went and
spoke at your organization
and it's a, it's you know what I thought
would be interesting is just
there's so much going on
in the world right now that
you touch on that you know,
a lot of us aren't familiar with.
You're very deeply involved
in the world of sports
which was, which is going
through something right now.
I'd love to learn more about it.
You are the chairman of the 2028 Olympics
and paralympic games in Los Angeles,
you do a lot of philanthropic work
so maybe a good place to
start Casey is you know,
tell us what it means you know,
I mean you can start wherever you like
and a lot of what we try
to do is kind of dig into
how you ended up becoming
who you are but what...
Tell those of us who
aren't familiar with these
especially the sports agency business,
what that business is and
maybe a little bit about
why you got interested
and how you got into it.
- Well, it's awesome to be with you.
I remember our first time
I came to your office
I actually was just going
through old pictures,
just cleaning out old pictures on my phone
and I found it where like the Khan Academy
was signed on a little grease board
like in a shared office space or something
so it was like a funny, funny
that I found it yesterday
right before we got on this today
so it's really fun for me to be with you.
The sports business,
as least as we operate,
we're a service business
so we have two kinds of,
two groups of clients if you will
which is how most sports
marketing agencies operate.
Either you can represent talent
which could be an athlete,
a coach, a broadcaster
in and around sports
obviously if you were beyond
sports it would be a musician
or an actor or writer or director
but in our case we're just
in sports so it's athletes,
it's 2,500 athletes across 35 sports
in our case which makes us
the biggest sports agency
in the world
and then the other side of the business
is how brands spend their money in sports
so very similar to how ad
agencies work for brands,
we work for brands
on how they spend their
sponsorship budgets, strategy,
the execution of those
arrangements, amplification
and then ultimately measurement
and then the other side of it is
how do properties attract those dollars
so if you're a team, a league, a property
and you wanna understand
what brands are thinking,
how they wanna spend their dollars,
what kind of assets they
need to tell their story
to connect with their consumers,
we help them structure and package that
and so that's sports marketing
kinda in its broadest sense of the word.
We operate pretty much across
the entirety of the business.
We have a thousand
employees around the world
and sports obviously is a,
while it's a global business,
it truly manifests itself locally
so if you're gonna be
relevant and present in sports
or in regions you have
to be in those places
which is sort of given the
desperate nature of our business.
- And what is the day-to-day
like of of what you do you know
someone who works at
Wasserman Agency, I mean,
you might have to do a lot of things
but you know for those of us
who are naive to this world
you know, we know the sports figures,
we know they play games,
we know that they, you know,
they get paid salaries,
we know there's some sense of economics
that there's advertising,
there's sponsorship,
there's ticket sales so
what does an agency do
for the various parties
especially for the sports figures
is at least how I conceptualize it?
- Yes, so for an athlete I mean,
you might imagine different
than other kinds of talents
because team sports athletes
and individual sports athletes
by the way are a little bit different
so team sports athletes have
a natural support structure
you know, you're in the
bay area, Clay Thompson
who's a client, The Warriors
are his support structure
during the season.
There's doctors, there's
food, there's travel,
there's obviously basketball,
there's health and wellness,
there's a traveling support team
when they're on the road all that stuff
and so the agent is there to
deal with the off the court
opportunities that
happen during the season.
Any other things that
might be an opportunity
as it relates to basketball,
if there's you know obviously
he wouldn't be a player
who would get traded
but players get traded
if they get injured, things happen
and then in the off season
we help them sort of manage their lives.
Now on the individual athletes side
like a professional golfer,
we help coordinate travel,
food, lodging, all that stuff setting,
the competitive schedule
actually entering them
in the tournaments, hiring
and firing of caddy,
dealing with sponsors,
arranging photo shoots,
fixing problems when they happen,
in many cases managing social media,
triaging social media problems
if they happen you know,
they wanna invest in a business,
they wanna buy an apartment
or a house that's across all athletes,
they wanna get married
or divorced or you know
there's a whole slew of things, you know,
I'm not sure the average age
of the people watching this
but if you've seen Jerry Maguire,
it's a pretty good
representation maybe not in style
but in substance.
- No, I think that was
most of our first exposure
and for me only exposure to this
but it is fascinating
'cause you imagine you know,
there's all these contract negotiations
and you read about it, you know,
actually I think would be great
math example word problems
of like if you win the
championship this happens
and if that happens, if you
get injured this happens.
There are these you know,
that's what I imagine
and you know where the
agents are very powerful
and important and most agents
have a background as lawyers,
if I understand.
- Yeah, yeah a lot are lawyers.
I would tell you to your point
about a sort of math lesson
you know, as you know
analytics and statistics
and data have become such
a big part of sports.
Obviously Moneyball started it in baseball
but it's now pervasive in sport.
That's how teams negotiate,
that's how they perceive value
and so we view as an
agency our responsibility
is to act on behalf of
our clients as you know
take the NFL as the 33rd team, right
so we have to have the
resources and data and analytics
and statistics and analysis
and financial understanding
of television contracts and
sponsor deals and local revenue
and national revenue and how
those all feed into each other,
salary cap projections, how
long of a deal should you make,
all those things so that we
can serve our clients best
because it has really become
a very much data, statistics,
financial driven model
and we need to do our best
to represent our clients
to achieve the best results
for them and it's really changed a lot.
It used to be relationships
and you owe me one here
because you signed that
guy and you underpaid him
so I needed to take care of my guy here
and those days are not over
but they're pretty much over
and so the whole,
if you will math of it
has changed dramatically
and ironically while a lot
of the agents are lawyers,
the legal part has been reduced
in many ways the contracts for team sports
are literally fill in the blank contracts,
the addendums are where
all the math happens
and that's the interesting part
but that's as much analytics, it is legal
so it's an interesting evolution
of the business for sure.
- Now it is interesting 'cause
when you realize in sports
more than anything it's very measurable.
The outcomes are very measurable,
the economics are very measurable
and so yeah it's probably
more than any other industry
is suited for this type of analysis.
There's a question coming off of YouTube
from Sudha Rani says,
"Hi, Casey when did you start?"
And so you know just how
did you get into this?
Did you always know that you
wanted to be a sports agent?
What drew you into this profession?
- I would say I always loved sports
like a lot of kids growing up
but I was a weird kid
and that I loved the business of sports,
kind of an odd thing to love.
I was, spent a summer as a bald
boy for the Cleveland Browns
and spent more time in the front office
than I did on the field frankly
so I've always loved the
business of sports and really...
In 2002, acquired our first little agency,
a tiny little action sports agency
that we still own today
that's quite big now
than the biggest action sports agency
and just built from there.
We were opportunistic, we were strategic,
we made lots of mistakes
and built in a way that we
thought was gonna create value
for the client and make a
point of differentiation for us
in a competitive industry
and so started with a larks sports agency,
bought a fairly big
basketball baseball agency
and then have bought a
ton of other agencies,
has hired lots of agents from competitors
and built a really
incredible group of business
based on great work of
about 130 sports agents
around the world and I'm
lucky enough to be able
to pursue and work in
my passion every day.
- And so it sounds like you...
It is what you imagined it to be?
- Yeah, I mean I would say
there are certainly things
that I do that I never imagined I would do
and certain things I get
to do that I never imagined
would be possible but what
I love about our business,
the diversity of our business,
is that no day is the same Sal.
We, I get to spend my days...
I really think focus on three things.
I focus on the strategy of the company,
I focus on the culture which
is about the work environment
for the people and I deal with problems
and if you think about human nature,
human nature is that you
stick your head in the sand
and hope problems go away
and the truth is problems
usually get worse
unless you deal with them
and so dealing with problems
but creating an organization
that actually supports people
communicating about
problems and rewards people
as opposed to penalizing them,
kinda turns the paradigm on its head
and I think the more you do,
the more successful you are,
the more problems you have
and the better you are
dealing with them is the
more successful you are
and so my days are, depends on
the day, depends on the week.
You can imagine during this period of time
we've had obviously
unprecedented issues to deal with
on behalf of our clients,
on behalf of our business
but from things like when
baseball players are trying to
come back to helping them think
about the economics of that,
the testing protocols you know,
using all of our resources
to help them make informed
decisions about playing.
We have players who are
player reps for their teams
in terms of all, they
represent all the players
on their team so you know
the diversity of what I do
is what I love and I get
to do it in a business
I'm passionate about in a world of sports
that I think is you know in
a world where you get to,
you don't always get to pick what you do,
I'm lucky to get to do it in
the world of sports every day.
- And I wanna dig deeper into that,
I definitely wanna go
get into what's going on
because of COVID because
that's obviously fascinating
but there's you know a couple
of folks off of Facebook
and YouTube, you know,
you quickly alluded to some
mistakes and struggles you made
but you kinda gave the very quick you know
you read in a magazine you
know, Casey started here,
he graduated there and then he
became the head of an agency
and they're very successful
and you know happy every,
happily ever after but you know,
it's never that way
and so you know from
Facebook Shaz Warwick asks,
"What type of mistakes have you made?"
From YouTube Parole Mytha asking,
"What are the struggles you
encountered on your way?"
From YouTube Susanna Dominguez,
"Could you describe a problem
"and how you overcame that problem?"
So yeah, give us a little bit of texture,
fill in the blanks.
Was this smooth sailing the whole time?
- Never and it's, there's no such thing
and I think one of the
misconceptions people have
in this day and age of
perceived instant success
is that success is a moment
in time and the truth
is my view of success is that
it comes from relentless consistency
and that pursuit of excellence
over a long period of time
relentlessly and when I talk
about dealing with bad news,
if you're able to
relentlessly pursue excellence
on a consistent basis it means
that the problems you have
you've been able to get through
and overcome and get to the other side
and so we have, there is
you know, as I like to say,
no one has ever come into my office
to give me something for nothing,
that just doesn't happen and
the truth is we're a better
organization because we're
better at dealing with problems,
it's why we're able to get
through a time like COVID,
2009 you know I mean I've now been the...
Started this business in 2002
so I've been running this
company for 18 years,
this is now the second time in my career
that I'm dealing with
something that was otherwise
supposed to be unprecedented,
that's unto itself unprecedented
and learning how to manage
through these things and ups
and downs and I can tell you
I was at the NBA all-star
game in February.
I didn't think that
less than 30 days later
the NBA would shut down for
good until hopefully a week
from now and my business
would be dramatically off in revenue,
I'd have to make all sorts
of difficult decisions
and our business by the way is I think
as stable and good and positive.
We didn't lay off significant
numbers of people,
we had like less than two percent
and that's really for
businesses that evaporated
because of this not
businesses that are just down
and working through an environment
like this is really difficult
but by the way problems
don't have to be big,
it can be a mistake by an
employee that you lose a client,
employee that causes a problem
internally in terms of culture
and the work environment.
There are, it can be a mistake
someone posts something on
social media they shouldn't
post who's an employee you know,
in the end my name's on
the door and my reputation
is at stake and so all
those things are important
and we take responsibility
for them and we take
focus on them in terms of
making sure we treat them
as we would all want to be treated
and there are literally problems every day
and so the reason I
think we have had success
is because we've been
doing it a long time,
I think we do it very well,
in the end we do it for
the benefit of our clients,
that's the only metric
we measure ourselves
by is the quality of work
and the longer you can do it,
the more consistently you can do it,
you can wake up today and
I have a thousand employees
and hundreds of millions
of dollars of revenue,
the action sports
business we bought in 2002
had less than a million dollars of revenue
and now if you told me in 2002
we'd be doing what we're doing today
with the number employees
we were doing it,
I would have said, no way.
I couldn't imagine how I'd get there
and I hope in five years
I'll be able to look back
and say that's all we were doing
and now we're doing all this
and you I can't tell you how
we're gonna get to that
point but it's again,
it's one of the things
I see most amongst the,
a younger generation
I think you and I are,
is they think that moment
of success is a moment
because of a singular action
and the truth is it never is.
It's the result of a lot of
work over a long period of time
through lots of up and downs.
- Did you ever have a moment
where you're just like
I don't think I'm gonna
make it, this isn't for me,
I don't have what it takes?
- No but that's probably just you know
my blind competitiveness.
I mean I am truly, crazy competitive
and so even if I was at the
brink of that happening,
I would never think that
'cause it's just not in my DNA
just like by the way enjoying success
is not particularly in my DNA either
so I would say I'm much more focused
on always driving forward.
I spend very little time worried about
what's in the rear view
mirror, good or bad
and so it's not any anything
that makes me better
than anybody else,
it's just in kind of in my DNA.
- I think we have some similarities.
I have had my moments
but then I'd go on a hike
and I said that squirrel doesn't care
that I just failed miserably
and embarrassed you know
myself and everything
and then I get over it
and I get back on track.
Before we go to COVID
'cause I think there's a whole many things
we can talk about there you know,
what's I think interesting
about being a sports agent
is obviously you are running a business,
you are a manager, you're
a leader for your team
but you're also I could
imagine an observer
of what these elite athletes are like
and I'm curious you know
from as an outsider's point of view,
we say oh look you know
so-and-so has god-given talent
so incredible et cetera, et cetera
but you see what goes
on behind the scenes,
you know what's your observation
of what makes talent great?
What makes people have enduring
and really successful careers in sports
and maybe what's surprising relative
to what most people think?
- Well I would say the
two things that are maybe
one surprising one not
but that one they are the elite athletes
are willing to make sacrifices
in some or significant parts
of their lives to be
the best at what they do
and people don't like to
admit that or own that
but they're, you cannot do it all
and they are they have chosen
to make those sacrifices
to dedicate themselves to their
craft to be at that level.
Obviously if anybody watched
the last dance on ESPN
about Michael Jordan, he
made incredible sacrifices
and incredible dedication to his craft
and that's what made him elite
in addition to clearly god-given talent
at a level maybe we've never seen before.
The other piece of it is
athletes are human beings,
they have all the same
insecurities, anxieties, fears,
concerns, worries, ups, downs,
issues with kids, partners,
loved ones, parents, finances, good, bad
like they are people and
all that stuff affects them
and maybe they're better
at compartmentalizing them
so that they can compete
but there are people
and they have all those issues too
so you know yes they can be role models,
yes they ought to carry
themselves in a way
'cause they do have influence
but we also need to understand.
I think part of this you started
to see with the recognition
that mental health is something
that affects everybody,
not some people, is that athletes
are starting to communicate
about mental health concerns
and issues that they have anxiety.
Kevin Love couldn't go on the court
because of an anxiety attack you know.
Most people wouldn't have
been comfortable to talk
about that and yet tens
of millions of people
in this country probably
had that happen this morning
and so they are people and I
think that surprises people
that they have all the same issues,
all the same stuff that
we all do every day
and they're able to
function and do their jobs
and maybe that's what makes them talented
on their field of play
but they're people too
and they can have really
bad days just like
we all can and really good
days just like we all can
and it's important to
keep that perspective.
- Yeah, that's super,
super valuable insight
and going into this COVID I
mean you alluded to it you know,
most professional sports have essentially
had to stop for the last
four, five, six months.
I'm curious your view,
well one how do you think
this is going to evolve?
I know that the NBA is doing
this kind of Disney world
I mean, what, how do
you think it's gonna...
How do you think it's gonna evolve
and let's just assume a
scenario where COVID lasts
well into next year
potentially even longer?
- Yeah so a couple things.
A bubble works, that's the good news
but it also is the bad news
because if you burst, if you
break the bubble you know,
you can get a really bad
situation really quickly.
Two, we are woefully
under-prepared as a country
to test at the level we
test at with the consistency
and the speed and the
accuracy we need to test at
to absent a medical solution
returned to as much as normal as possible
so I compare baseball now playing 60 games
and empty stadiums, the NFL
likely to play its entire season
mostly in empty stadiums,
college football being completely canceled
probably if not delayed until the spring
and the premier league in England
has announced they're gonna
play up to 50 capacity
and I think they might
even get close to 100%
because the testing in the UK
has gotten so good, so quick,
so consistent, so accurate
and essentially everybody has an app
on their phone with their test results
so if you pass the test,
you can go to the premier
league game that day
and so testing is the
answer in the short term.
Everybody you know,
Nirvana would be everybody
tested every day.
That solves 95% of the
problems we're in right now
in terms of people having a normal life
whether it's going to a sporting event
or going to a gym or going to
get you know get a manicure,
it doesn't really matter if we are testing
and we know and then being
responsible in your behavior.
Masks, hand washing, all
those things it sounds trite,
it's not political, it's fact, it works.
Keep your distance, wear
a mask, wash your hands,
you're likely not to get
COVID even in an environment
where it exists and with pervasive testing
we can return to as much
as normalcy as possible
until there's a medical solution
whether that's in six months or two years
as you said and no one knows to be fair
and so sports is at effect if you will
until that testing
exists, we can't do that.
You know there's enough testing to test
a thousand NBA players every day
that's fine or baseball players
but there's not enough tests
to test 300 million Americans every day
or every other day and
that's the problem we're in
and that's really one of
the great disappointments
I have about that here
we are five months later
and you know,
on the other hand we're
talking about vaccines
may be coming quickly
but we're still only testing
three million people a day
and I'm no math expert, I think you are
but if you have to give the vaccine twice
like most vaccines do
and certainly like the
Oxford one appears to be,
that's 700 million
injections plus or minus.
If you're only giving 3
million a day that's 200 days
before you even get everybody vaccinated,
if everyone agrees, if you started today
and if you had all the
vials and all that you know
like it's a real process here
so like I don't think we're prepared
and you know I went to
UCLA as John Wooden said,
failing to prepare is preparing to fail.
- It's a, that's a good quote.
What do you think is going
to happen to the sports?
I mean it sounds like the sports industry
is figuring out a way to proceed
and I'm not an expert
in the economics of it,
is the bulk of the economics,
our TV and sponsorship so even
with empty stadiums it'll,
it won't have the same
energy or the same feel
but do you think it'll be okay?
- It will be okay, it
won't be obviously ideal
or great and it depends on the sports.
Now some sports predominantly
get their revenues
from tickets and some sports predominantly
get their revenue from
TV and you can imagine
the further you are on the
TV end of the spectrum,
the more stable you are
and the further you are on the
ticket end of the spectrum,
the more you're gonna have problems
so a sport like tennis well
in its competitive sense
feels very safe 'cause
they are clearly far apart
from each other physically,
90% of the revenue comes from ticket sales
so that's why you haven't
seen a tennis match
and by the way players
from all over the world
traveling all over the
world that's a problem
and then a sport like the
NFL that has so much revenue
even though it's a majority
it's just a lot of ticket revenue,
from television they can
play games and it's worth it
to play games and everything
else is kind of in the middle
and the other piece of it is
you can get through a year
or two of this at most.
I would tell you most
leagues are thinking about
for the 2021 season for
like the NBA and the NHL
who start at the end of
'20 for their 2021 season
or the NFL and major baseball
will play complete seasons
in '21 or major league soccer,
I think they're figuring
maybe on a blended basis
you can have 30-40% fans
for the whole of a season
which may means you start out
at the beginning of the
season with no fans,
get to a reduced capacity scenario
and then maybe by the end of the '21,
2021 seasons you can get pretty
close to full capacity so
and then the next year after
get back to a sense of normalcy
in terms of capacity and filling stadiums
and that's obviously what
people are hoping for
but hope doesn't solve
the problems which is why
we need to focus on things
like testing and responsible behavior.
- That makes a lot of sense
and you know, even before a COVID,
what did you think was going to be
kind of the evolution
or the future of sports?
You know, there's questions
here about things like VR
for sports viewing from Rickmon Facebook.
I mean is there a view
that this is how sports
are gonna look in five or 10 years
and has COVID changed that view at all?
- Couple things.
I think one of the things that hasn't.
So a few, few things to
remember about sports,
I think it's truly the only defensible
piece of the media
business, it matters live,
it can't and won't be time
shifted, it's evergreen
and all those things
that make it relevant,
it's truly local, right?
You love your local team it matters,
it's kinda embedded the
community in a special way
and sports has really
been for the last 25 years
optimized for television
because the great majority
if not almost 100% of people
only consume sports on TV.
I mean I think the NFL has a
stat that 97% of avid NFL fans
will never see a game in person
and so you've seen the
television experience optimized,
the in stadium experience relatively,
I mean if you wanna
look 20 years ago today
maybe the stadiums are newer and nicer
and the tickets are clearly more expensive
but the experience hasn't changed a lot.
I think COVID will change
the experience a lot,
focus a lot more on
the customer experience
and I'm not just talking about health
and safety protocols which
clearly need to be better,
I'm talking about why
are we waiting in line
for 20 minutes for concessions?
Why do we wait lines for bathrooms?
Why do we have cash and slow things down?
Why you know again what why
isn't the experience better
so that the customer gets more benefit?
All those things obviously
have health and safety benefits
but they have customer benefits
so I think that will happen for sure
and then the other thing
you're gonna you have seen
and we'll see I think
accelerate aggressively
is this sort of transition
to different monetizations of content.
So obviously we can watch
on TV free for the most part
or on some cable channels,
there's gonna be direct to
consumer for all the leagues,
there's gonna be a lot more gambling,
there's gonna be a lot more
buying of short forms of games,
there's gonna be a lot more buying
of a couple minutes of the ends of games.
I think the consumption of sports
is gonna continue to
accelerate and be pervasive.
I think the points of
where you will consume it
will start to evolve slower
probably than people think
and I think ancillary ways to consume it
will probably accelerate
faster than people think.
- Super, super interesting
and these conversations always
go much faster than I expect.
I do wanna make sure
we get to the Olympics
'cause that's fascinating,
I mean you're the chairman of the Olympics
in Los Angeles in 2028.
I guess a bunch of questions
I'll bundle together
you answered however you like,
how did you get into that role
why were you interested in it
and kind of where do you see
is the value of the Olympics?
Like what, you know why
are you putting the time
and energy into it the way you are?
- So I was asked by Mayor
Garcetti of Los Angeles
to lead the bid which
was the summer of 2014
we started this process.
It's actually something I
thought was a, I joke with him,
that was a terrible idea
and that's why he's mayor
and I'm not but that was a terrible idea
and I thought we would lose
and it was a fool's errand
and he convinced me that he's the mayor
and I don't really have a choice
so if I wanted my trash picked up,
I better chair the bid so here I am.
I happened to be a kid of Los Angeles.
I was 10 years old in 1984 when
the Olympics were in my city
and I saw what an
incredible experience it was
so I absolutely loved the Olympics,
bidding for the Olympics is
a different kind of thing
and now that we have the Olympics...
Look being chair in my role in Los Angeles
is different than any other city on earth.
We have the physical resources here
unlike any city in the world
and it doesn't start with sports stadiums
which in this day and
age most people have,
it really starts with USC and UCLA
which is kind of counterintuitive.
No city on earth has two big universities
that have athletic programs at that scale
that are in the city center
10 miles from each other.
Lots of cities have big universities,
lots of cities has great universities,
some have athletics, some don't,
some are in the city center, some aren't.
LA is unique and so the
combination of the scale
of Los Angeles, the facilities
we have on the sports
side but USC and UCLA
as a starting point means
we can host the Olympics
without building a new
venue and that's no,
there's no sort of comma there and a but,
it's legitimately we don't
have to build a new venue
so the athletes who we will have to house
will move into the dorms
at UCLA for the Olympics,
the media who we house will
move into the dorms at USC.
We've got stadiums and
practice facilities and arenas,
we have I mean there's
even a model Sal here
if you wanna talk about a
fun words problem you know,
take the Rubik's cube of of
Olympic sports and venues
and map it out in terms of
transportation logistics
and all that stuff someone
would have fun with that
but there's an environment
where we can host the Olympics
in Los Angeles and not use a
single venue in Orange County
and by the way you've got
great basketball, hockey arena,
great baseball stadium
not use dodger stadium
and not use the rose bowl and
still host the Olympics easily
and so, not saying that
that's what will happen
but that's a real scenario
and so we've got an
incredible set of facilities
and if we do this right,
I think the economic and the cultural
and the community impact
will be staggering
as part of our commitment to
the hosting the games of '28,
we agreed to fund COVID aside,
we agreed to fund 160
million dollars to subsidize
youth sports in Los Angeles
for kids in the city
so the youth sports
was free for everybody.
That's a powerful, that's the
biggest investment in sports
in the history of this country in one city
and it's a powerful statement
that literally has a chance
to change this community forever
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
if we do our job right in
executing the Olympics.
- That's incredible.
I also remember the '84 Olympics very well
obviously watching it on TV
and I still have the memories
of they had that tall
guy to play the alien,
that was a very memorable moment for me
and you know what it
is, it just makes you,
it captures the imagination and you know,
I can't imagine how cool it
is to be at the center of that
also how stressful it is
'cause the logistics you
just described don't seem,
don't seem easy but Casey--
- It is the big, it is
the biggest event on earth
I mean it's crazy the
Olympics are the biggest event
on earth by every measure.
The Paralympics are the
third biggest event on earth
by every measure and they
will happen in the same city
in 30 days.
- Wow, wow and you have got until 2028
so I'm hopefully we'll
be through COVID by then
and everything will be back
to normal and all of that.
Well Casey thank you so much.
This was super valuable you
know, it gives us a lens,
it gives me the lens into
a world that you know
we enjoy but we don't understand
all of what's going on
and I could have asked you
questions for several more hours
but you know, thank you
and thanks for you know,
being a supporter of the work we do
and I hope there's more ways
that we can work together
and figure out ways to help more folks.
- Well it's my pleasure
and I appreciate you
and you know what a fan of
yours and all that you do,
I am and proud to have
known you a long time
and be a supporter
and your name might be
a bad name in my house
'cause I tell my kids when
they ask me a question
I go just go on Khan Academy
but other than that I love you
and always happy to support you.
- Wonderful.
Well thank you so much Casey.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for joining.
Well everyone, thanks again for joining
what is always a fascinating conversation.
I learned a lot, I feel very
lucky to be able to do this
and ask people questions about the things
that are very relevant in the world.
I did just get an announcement,
a team member Philipe
just told me unfortunately
we were all very excited
about tomorrow's conversation
with Anthony Fauci.
Just found out that, we're not sure why
but they've had to cancel,
we're gonna see if we can reschedule.
I had a lot of questions
and I know you all had a lot of questions
but I'm sorry to say that
we will not be having
the interview with Dr Fauci
tomorrow but stay tuned.
Hopefully we'll be able to get
something else on the books
but with that thanks for joining again
and you'll see me at least one
or two more times this week,
for better or for worse, you know,
stay safe with all the COVID going around
and do everything that Casey
just mentioned about the masks
and social distance
and all that I think that is
definitely our best option
so with that I will see
you later this week.